okay it's finally time for Donald
Trump's convicted lawyer personal lawyer
Michael Cohen to testify under oath
before the House Oversight and Reform
Committee scheduled to happen tomorrow
Wednesday there is a New York Times
report corroborated by other reporting
which says that Michael Cohen will be
coming prepared with documents to
support allegations of criminality by
Donald Trump again he will be under oath
and expected to accuse the President of
the United States of committing crimes
Cowen's allies are saying that it's
testimony is going to include stories
about Donald Trump's racist use of
language that won't be a huge surprise
he will come prepared with documents
that will expose Donald Trump's lies
about his wealth we've also long
suspected that but most importantly what
I will be paying attention to and what I
hope many others will as well including
the Republicans on that committee is
allegations by Michael Cohen of specific
criminal conduct that Donald Trump has
allegedly participated in now what might
it be related to the most likely
scenario is that it's criminality
related to those mistress hush money
payments that Michael Cohen has among
other things that now been convicted for
or pled guilty to remember that Cohen
was convicted for his involvement in
those payments and all along Donald
Trump has been claiming that he just
knew nothing about it whatsoever he
wasn't involved he had no idea over time
though we've realized that Trump did
know about it Trump was involved he was
allegedly directing a lot of what was
being done and now Michael Cohen has the
opportunity to say that the crimes he
was convicted of were specifically
directed by Donald Trump if he had the
documents to back it up it would be all
the more extraordinary so issue number
one of possible Trump criminality are
these mistress hush money payments the
second issue where Michael Cohen may
allege criminality criminal wrongdoing
by Donald Trump is that Trump Tower
Moscow deal
ultimately didn't happen once again for
a very long time Donald Trump has been
claiming that Trump Tower Moscow was
barely an ocean there were no real
discussions there were no plans of
course we found out over the last six
weeks or so that there were plans a
specific builder in Russia had been
lined up they had the specific idea of
gifting the 50 million dollar penthouse
to Vladimir Putin to make the entire
building sort of more exciting and
appealing to other people and a number
of significant lives could be exposed by
Michael Cohen a told by Donald Trump in
tomorrow's testimony now the reason that
this is so important is that it's
possible that in those written answers
to questions that Donald Trump's
attorneys submitted to robert muller
it's possible that donald trump via his
attorneys lied related to the trump
tower moscow fiasco and if Michael Cohen
tomorrow is able to present specific
evidence indicating that Donald Trump
lied under oath right I mean those
answers to Robert Moeller's team were
submitted as if they were under oath
testimony that is potentially massive
one of Michael Cohen's lawyers Lanny
Davis put out a statement about what to
expect he says that Michael Cohen quote
worked very hard on this moment to not
only tell the truth but to back it up
with documents so this is going to be
absolutely fascinating on a few levels
do you expect that that we will see
actual bombshells
in public testimony or previously when
we talked about this you said you were
under the impression that the real
bombshells would only come in private
what do you expect here generally we
don't get the bombshells out in public
there's usually something to be hid in
there but because Michael Cohen is in a
position where he just wants to come
clean I think he's already going to
prison after all he's cooperating with
the Muller team I do suspect that he's
going to want to unveil some of those
bombshells and make them public because
that would certainly embarrass the
president and I think at this point
that's what he's going for that seems
to be one of Michael Cohen's priorities
at this point and I will be watching
very closely tomorrow Donald Trump's
Twitter account because Donald Trump
will be in Vietnam for the Kim Jong Un's
summit number two trump's aides are
already worried that his behavior trumps
by the way not kim jong un's that
trump's behavior will be even more
erratic than normal because of Cowen's
testimony what is Trump going to be
doing on Twitter that should be a wild
ride but I'm also going to be paying
close attention to what is the reaction
of Republican members of Congress to
what Michael Cohen says they are going
to come prepared with attack questions
to try to make Michael Cohen look like
an unreliable liar and there are likely
going to be fireworks when Republicans
get their shot at questioning Michael
Cohen obviously Trump and his cronies
are going to accuse Cohen of lying and
of making stuff up and of being just an
unreliable guy remember though Cohen
will be under oath under possible
penalty of perjury if he lies and he
supposedly is bringing documents to back
up his claims you would have to be
really dumb if you were Michael Cohen to
lie in these situations now and just
think back to Paul Manafort
Trump's convicted campaign chairman Paul
Manafort made a plea deal then lied and
that plea deal was almost immediately
revoked and Manafort now faces up to the
rest of his life in prison this is very
serious we have every indication that
Cohen has been telling the truth to
investigators and prosecutors since he
started speaking to them and this could
be c-span's best ratings day ever so in
the order of what to watch number one
what does Cohen say does he back it up
with documents number two how does Trump
respond number three how do Republicans
respond and number four does it do
anything to shift public opinion about
the President of the United States we
probably know the answer to that last
question
and the answer is probably no today's
show is made possible in part by Sun
basket giving everybody in our audience
60% off their first box when you go to
get Sun basket calm slash Pakman you'll
get six dinners delivered to your door
for just 20
$8.00 Sun basket is a meal kit service
that brings fresh ingredients for ready
to cook recipes right to your home but
what separates Sun basket from other
meal plan services is Sun baskets
eco-friendly food eco-friendly packaging
their commitment to organic ingredients
and their ability to fit almost any kind
of diet whether it's low-carb
gluten-free paleo vegetarian or vegan
pescetarian Mediterranean Sun basket
also has amazing meal plans even if you
don't have dietary restrictions just
choose what kind of meal plan you want
the number of recipes you want to
receive each week and Sun basket lets
you choose which individual recipes you
get before they're sent to you so you're
always getting something you love and
the recipes change every week you can
even choose when the meals show up at
your home you can skip weeks which is
also really convenient
everything arrives totally fresh all the
ingredients are pre measured so cooking
is a breeze and all of the recipes take
less than 30 minutes to make so it's
perfect for people with busy lives sign
up for affordable tasty healthy organic
eco friendly recipes brought straight to
your home ready to cook and save 60% off
your first week of meals when you go to
get Sun basket calm slash Pakman six
dinners delivered to your door for just
28 bucks I've put a link right
underneath this video